bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
tout de suite le sommaire
basket en nationale 3 le fc trappes
saint quentin en yvelines a remporté le
derby face au chesnay versailles sur le
score de 81 à 65 le résumé du match dans
ce journal
handball montigny-le-bretonneux est
actuellement co leader de nationale 2
féminine nous reviendrons sur les bonnes
performances du club dans cette édition
avec le coach philippe l'étrange et
l'arrière fanny jean baptiste nous
parlerons également du titre de champion
du monde de l'équipe de france football
américain les templiers d'elancourt
débutent leur championnat ce samedi
contre les cougars de
saint-ouen-l'aumône entretien dans cette
édition avec le président du club jean
jacques gosso sino alexander 7 sont
joints des hauts templiers et puis en
fin d'émission tous les résultats du
week end
on commence ce journal sport par la
belle victoire en basket de tra face au
chesnay versailles sur son terrain 81 à
65 les trappistes compte désormais 22
points dans ce championnat de nationale
3 l'homme les montages romain respini
le bouillant derby blinois trappe le
chesnay a tenu toutes ses promesses mené
62 61 sur son parc à 4 minutes 20 de la
fin du match les trappistes ont su
renverser la rencontre dans les derniers
instants pour l'emporter
81-65 après trois quart-temps très
compliqué au début je pense qu'on les a
un peu pris de haut
et par la suite on a commencé à se
mettre dedans et ils sont revenus et je
veux dire je pense que comme je dis
souvent à la somme de chaque individu je
pense que c'est ça qui a fait la
différence on n'arrivait pas à se
trouver même si la volonté est que là on
n'arrive vraiment pas à faire des extras
passe et le contrat remédier à ça et par
la suite on a réussi à retrouver nos
joueurs et retrouver notre jour notre
groupe était déstabilisé au départ parce
que en fait il nous manquait notre pivot
et
cette blessure qui t'arrive au dernier
moment les a déstabilisés ils sont ils
ont effectivement comme le disait yann
tout à l'heure du mal à rentrer dans le
match grâce à cette victoire trappe
remonte à la huitième place du
championnat de nationale 3 avec 22
points en 15 journées en plus un impact
direct sur le classement cette victoire
dans le dernier permet de booster le
moral des joueurs de mostafa el hafidi
c'était super important pour éviter de
se faire des frayeurs par la suite donc
la c1 en compte encore deux trois
les objectifs c'est tout d'abord de
gagner les deux prochains matches et des
c'est d'essayer de finir l'année
avec un esprit de groupe prochain match
pour le fc trappes saint quentin en
yvelines samedi prochain à 20 heures sur
le terrain de malakoff victoire
impérative pour assurer le maintien
après le basket place ronde balle gros
plan aujourd'hui sur les féminines de
montigny le bretonneux et l'équipe de
france de ronde
alors je reçois ce soir sur ce plateau
philippe l'étrange le coach de
montigny-le-bretonneux doucement et nous
rendrait également fanny jean baptiste
arrière-droit de montigny-le-bretonneux
alors on commence tout de suite par
l'actualité durant balle français je
veux bien sûr parler donc de la victoire
handball de l'équipe de france 25 à 22
face au qatar vous l'avez regardé ce
match bien sûr et du coup vous en avez
pensé quoi beau match un peu viril en
deuxième mi temps je pense que si les
français n'avaient pas eu d' échec au
tir face à un très bon gardien en face
le score était plus ample d'accord il ya
un petit mot un petit mot sur le qatar
aussi qui a réalisé quand même une belle
performance en sept ans ces championnats
du monde mes performances en
naturalisant pas mal d'erreurs mais un
mot parcours et je pensais pas qu'ils
arriveraient en finale et c'est vrai que
vous avez à arriver à comprendre j'ai du
mal à l'heure actuelle mais je pense
qu'on en saura un peu plus dans les
jours à venir et donc les français
deviennent équipe la plus titrée
handball avec cinq titres mondiaux
comment expliquez vous ces performances
toujours l' envie de gagner je pense
qu'ils sont intransigeants envers
eux-mêmes envers l'équipe lorsque
quelqu'un rap qui en a pas un qui rallie
reviennent tous compenser le rater c'est
impressionnant c'est très impressionnant
de les voir comme ça et ça se joue à la
détection peut-être la détection
peut-être le groupe peut-être les cadres
qui font en sorte que tout le monde se
sente bien et peut-être qu'ils se
parlent quand ça va pas et ce par le
fort en face à face
il faut être faut faire partie de
l'équipe pour savoir vraiment ce qui se
passe mais vu de l'extérieur c'est
impressionnant et la fédé justement nous
peu coquin nouveaux talents où je pense
pas je pense qu'il ya une structure
fédérale qui est importante avec les
jeunes
l'épaule mais bon je pense qu'ils qui
balaye un peu partout donc ils gagnent
tous depuis depuis 20 ans on va dire
comment expliquer cette longévité
justement je pense qu'il ya une bonne
cohésion de l'équipe un groupe assez
solide
qui permet aux jeunes de s'intégrer
beaucoup plus facilement et rapidement
en fait ils sont assez rigoureux
ils donnent généralement tout ce qu'ils
ont notamment les jeunes et je trouve
que l'ensemble fait que ça les amène ou
sur le toit du monde à l'heure actuelle
et vous pensez pas que la motivation va
s'user avec le temps j'espère pas
j'espère pas ce serait dommage que ça
s'arrête ainsi donc je pense que ça va
ça va perdurer ils sont toujours morts
de faim sassareu et de toute façon les
voit on avait l'impression que c'était
leur premier titre à la fin là est tout
le monde saute et même le nouvel
entraîneur de la défense dinars qui
sautait que c'est un peu non il ya
également un joueur qui a un qui est une
révélation va dire sur ce tournoi c'est
valentin porte il est versailles et il
joue arrière droit comme vous c'est un
modèle un modèle
oui et non parce qu'en fait la
différence avec valentin valentin porte
c'est que je ne suis pas gauchère il est
gaucher donc il a un petit avantage en
plus sur moi et puis enfin c'est pas au
même niveau mais oui c'est un bel
exemple fouet et vous prenez justement
des petits gestes à lui ou pas ou
comparer le handball féminin ou masculin
c'est un peu compliqué parce que du coup
les chocs et les performances sont elles
mêmes mais on essaye de s'inspirer
parfois de certains joueurs oui voyez ce
que ça vous pousse justement ah ça oui
ça pousse vers le christ est est ce
qu'on ressent l'impact justement que ces
victoires 11 / sur madère les amateurs
de hand au niveau des jeunes surtout en
oui parce que là aujourd'hui dans les
écoles tout le monde en parlait donc
c'est quand même bien me médiatisé et
puis rentrer vers en septembre avec
peut-être d'autres influences dans des
inscriptions dans les clubs devant
justement les inscriptions on pensait
qu'elles vont être boostés oui c'est
qu'il faut avoir les gens exploitation
pour pouvoir les accueillir parce que si
on dépasse le seuil et qu'on fait que de
la garderie c'est pas très intéressant
pour tout le monde et vous à montigny
vous en avait parlé
un petit peu entre vous moi un moment
pas encore mais je pense qu on en
discutera demain lors de l'entraînement
mais on en parle par message avec elle
certaines supportrices et donc on
revient à votre quotidien donc vous êtes
co leader de nationale 2 actuellement
est-ce que vous assumer ce nouveau
statut
ça ça crée une pression supplémentaire
peut-être une pression oui parce que on
a on se rend compte qu'on a plus
vraiment le droit à l'erreur et quelques
erreurs en première partie de saison
mais oui à l'heure actuelle on a un peu
peur parce que on sait que la première
place on l'a mais ça suit derrière de
peu de points donc il va falloir assurer
sur tous les matches à venir philippe
étrange est ce que vous sentez que vous
n'êtes plus attendu maintenant chaque
déplacement cire actuellement parce que
l'objectif c'était de terminer dans les
cinq premiers et puis plus ça va plus on
est dans le haut du classement on a
battu premier chez chez elle dernier
match donc c'est sûr que tout le monde
va nous attendre parce que là on peut
plus cacher qu'on va terminer en scène
premier l'avant vise les six possibles
les deux premières places là pour
l'instant ça dépend que de nous on gagne
tous nos matches on sera au moins
deuxièmes derrière le havre si elles
font pas
les jean-baptiste vous vous sentez que
vous êtes maintenant parmi les favoris
je sens oui on est parmi les favoris oui
le classement parle de lui-même
sa chose c'est que comme je voulais dire
on a peu de marges et on attend notre
résultat en priorité et puis le résultat
des autres ensuite pour voir si on a une
marge assez assez solides pour pouvoir
se dire mais on peut respirer enfin quoi
parce que là on est un peu en apnée la
cpi et qu'est ce qui fait votre force
selon vous
peut-être un peu comme l'équipe de
france un autre niveau une autre un
niveau nettement est une petite équipe
de france en fait c'est ça non
avec des jeunes incorporés des jeunes
cette année donc c'est pas toujours tout
rose parce que mais c'est la vie de
groupe et on en a réussi à se dire les
choses en face quand ça allait pas pu
remplir partie de mon pied et voit les
jeunes les anciennes et voilà ça je
pense à faire un bon groupe là on peut
avoir peut-être une ou deux blessés ce
que j'espère pas mais on peut il ya des
remplaçantes et sans que l'équipe perde
beaucoup donc ça c'est intéressant
justement vous allez rentrer dans la
dernière ligne droite
qu'est ce qui peut vous empêcher
justement de finir au delà du podium
ce qui peut empêcher je pensais
attaquer potentiel blessures ou les
absentes parce que ben on a un groupe
assez solide et il faut que toutes les
personnes
les pièces maîtresses de l'équipe soit
là
après
il faut qu'on
essaye de jouer notre jeu qu'on joue
simple et qu'on se prenne pas à la tête
serait l'idéal serait d'assurer notre
position bien plus tôt dans le
championnat parce que je voyais à la
montée sur les derniers matchs ça risque
d'être un peu compliqué et donc il y a
un match ce samedi à 20h30 contre le
mans vous le préparez comment ce match à
domicile en son domicile alors on se
méfie parce que le mans n'a pas gagné de
match cette année maintenant avant venir
vont certainement descendre sans
pression on sait des matches pièges et
puis surtout les deux matches qui
suivent ceux des matches très importants
pour nous on va chez le troisième via
val d'orge et là il faudrait bien aller
gagner à val d'or si on veut les mettre
un peu plus loin donc victoire
impérative se joue ce week-end contre
lequel bien sûr tout en préparant le
match suivant merci philippe l'étrange
merci fanny jean baptiste donc beau
courage pour la suite du championnat ils
on passe maintenant en cyclisme sur
piste
la sélection française pour les
championnats du monde sur piste a été
dévoilé par la fédération du 18 au 22
février
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
grégory baugé virginie cueff la plaisir
aux incendies claire et ligne et
montrent un françois pervis les images
sont signés william l
la liste des sélectionnés français pour
les championnats du monde sur piste est
tombé pas de surprise les têtes
d'affiché seront bien présentes au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 18 au 22
février les spectateurs pourront voir en
action grégory baugé 110 claire ou
encore françois pervis sur la vitesse
thomas boudât et bryan coquard sont
alignés dans les épreuves d'endurance
une sélection compétitive
transporte les joueurs est difficile
puisque les critères étaient précis donc
les athlètes savez très bien où vous
allez ils savaient qu'ils allaient avoir
une chance et comme on leur a rappelé
lors du bilan c'est que l'équipe de
france en donne une chance par contre il
ne faut pas la louper puisque le jour de
la course il va falloir être présent au
jour j ai donc faut saisir sa chance et
simplement nouvelle coqueluche du
cyclisme sur piste tricolore françois
pervis fait logiquement partie de la
sélection française triple champion du
monde à cali en colombie en 2014 lit ni
mon teint n'arrivera pas dans les
meilleures conditions cette année le
pistard a été perturbée par des
blessures pendant sa préparation des
doutes il y en a forcément un petit peu
parce que je suis quand même
- je me sens moins fort que l'année
dernière à la même époque
donc là aujourd'hui je veux pas je peux
pas vous dire je vais gagner les trois
titres de champion du monde que j'ai
déjà gagné l'année dernière
je vais faire je fais avec comme je le
dis c'est comme ça c'est le sport et
puis moi je de toute façon quoi qu'il
arrive je donnerai le meilleur de moi
même et je suis rien lâcher objectif
annoncé par la fédération française de
cyclisme récolter au minimum cinq
médailles sur ces championnats du monde
pour atteindre ce but les sportifs
compte sur le soutien du public français
ça on en voit un championnat du monde à
l'étranger un bien sûr c'est chez nous
donc c'est un peu plus excitant mais
warner on se souvient de revanche à
prendre par rapport à 2006 et puis et
puis on sait très bien que roi de tous
les français qui étaient des arts nous à
londres ont envie de nous voir briller
dans quelques semaines donc voilà après
ça nous dépasse et s'emballe et
d'être trop excité par rapport à
l'événement le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines affiche
presque complet pour les cinq jours de
compétition le nouvel écrin du sport
français attend désormais le 18 février
pour vibrer au rythme des exploits des
champions tricolores
mauvaise nouvelle pour le camp tricolore
thomas boudât est tombé jeudi dernier
pendant le trophée de majorque sa
participation n'est pas remise en cause
mais il serait sûrement diminué pour les
championnats du monde on s'intéresse
maintenant football américain et plus
précisément aux templiers d'elancourt
nous recevons ce soir sur ce plateau
jean jacques austin au président et
templiers d'elancourt
et lorsqu'on également alexander atsa
tsong donc joueurs aux templiers
d'elancourt je remplis de l'encours
alors le championnat élite redémarre ce
week-end donc les templiers d'elancourt
seront les cougars ce samedi à 20 heures
la rencontre est programmée au complexe
sportif europe pour nous parler donc de
se pré match où alexandre de samsung
donc ce match vous vous préparez comment
on entre en prépa en fait depuis depuis
janvier f1 depuis début d'année puisque
on connaît déjà le calendrier entend les
couverts cynique pour connais assez bien
on connaît pas les nouveaux un port qui
vient d'arriver mais eux non plus ne
connaissent pas nous en port on a des
qualités physiques qui vont faire qu'on
peut on pourra les plus éculés sur leur
jeu maintenant on se préparer
on verra samedi mais bon je pense que je
pourrais vraiment donné de résultats qui
après moi j'en fais donc on verra ce que
ça va donner vous sentez vous êtes prêts
oui on est de plus en plus près tout à
fait bas et fectivement on verra ça
samedi soir enfin l'équipe te prépares
lé pa depuis janvier se prépare depuis
fin septembre début octobre on a
accéléré la préparation de 2 pb à 3
semaines un mois mais voilà du coup ça
se passe comment la préparation c'est
c'est des matches amicaux c'est quoi oui
il ya eu toute une phase physique son
casque et épaulières après on commence
plus tôt qui intégrait l'équipe ans il
ya eu un match amical d'accord vous avez
remporté à une équipe réserve on a la
chance d'avoir une équipe réserve qui
joue en 3e division cette année on a
fait deux matches contre eux et vous
pensez que vous avez les recettes du
coup pour remporter ce match
physiquement parlant et je vais dire par
rapport à nos capacités individuelles on
a les moyens de gagner ce match
maintenant j'ai pas trop de soucis à
faire pour les premiers matches de
l'année je pense que ça va être plus tôt
en deuxième deuxième période de saison
ou pour nous ça va être plus compliqué
avec un effectif réduit mais sinon je
pense qu'on a les capacités pour des
pour bien redémarrer cette saison
vraiment 2014 2015 et il faut
impérativement gagner ce premier match
oui bien sûr ça donnera le temps poteau
pour toute la saison on sachant que les
cougars bas c'est un peu notre bête
noire on a toujours eu des difficultés
contre eux voilà ça devrait vraiment en
pop la saison si on gagne ce match la
saison super secondes et du coup quelles
sont vos objectifs donc pour cette
nouvelle saison on sait que l'année
dernière vous avez réalisé un beau
parcours notamment avec une belle
demi-finale de coupe d'europe perdue
mais de peu est ce que justement les
objectifs seront élevés cette saison
l'objectif sont toujours les mêmes dopés
à trois ou quatre ans depuis qu'on a
perdu la finale du championnat de france
en 2008 dont caen veut retourner à cette
finale de chopin de france à charléty à
paris donc et l'a remporté et dont
l'objectif est toujours le même même si
d'allée en allée bas l'effectif
changement à peu voilà justement
l'effectif donc votre équipe enregistre
donc l'arrivée de caudillo agent et zach
chaud nous avons rencontré cette semaine
je veux gagner le titre de champion de
france j'espère que nous aurons beaucoup
de succès je veux emmener le club le
plus haut possible en europe
je veux gagner des titres depuis ma
naissance et j'espère que cela va
arriver avec elle en cours
j'ai vu que les templiers d'elancourt
été l'une des meilleures équipes en
france j'ai eu des contacts avec le
coach emmanuel charest qui m'a convaincu
et je suis ici maintenant
l'entraîneur donne des bons conseils en
ce moment nous sommes en train de
travailler les positions sur les phases
offensives
nous avons une bonne relation de travail
et je suis très heureux
ap auteur
dont convient de voir cody redman des
axes chaud pourquoi les avez-vous choisi
alors ça c'est pas c'est le coach
principal et benoît charest qu'il a
choisi donc il ya tout un système de
vidéo des changes de vidéos et autres
donc voilà c'est le quarterback on l'a
choisi parce que l'ancien et partir en
autriche
et le design donc on dit pareil pareil
paraguay on avait des besoins c'est à
ces deux postes donc on était vraiment
on a visé ces postes là après les
joueurs ben sanou quelques mois quelques
semaines de visionnage vidéo pour
arriver
et donc vous vous entraîner avec eux
avec eux avec toutes les semaines on va
se mettre à présent à tous les
entraînements ils sont assidus voilà
après on essaie de leur montrer qu'en
france quand même voilà on est un
certain niveau aussi le voit à
l'entraînement de toute façon au cours
de l'année on va voir d'autres équipes
avec des impôts américain donc voilà le
système est déjà bien ancré en france
avec ses imports américain qui joue les
matches et voilà on est sur une bonne
dynamique en soit vous sentez qui sont
au dessus les français qui sont au
dessus des français ça dépend des
américains après on sent quand même
qu'il ya vraiment une différence ce sont
vraiment des avec la culture du football
américain en son sens vraiment qu'ils
s'entraînent tous les jours maintenant
ça peut pas empêcher des français de
montrer qu'ils ont en fait le niveau
pour jouer au niveau international et
donc va apporter codir edmonds on s'est
fait remettre 88 120 kg c'est quoi ces
cdu points ou plus dans la défense
pendant plus ou une certaine sécurité à
ce poste-là
on avait des petites faiblesses oui on
va le dire parce qu'on la perde une mac
douglas qui était chez nous depuis
quelques années donc il vient remplacer
pratiquement poste par poste l'autre
américaine connaît qu'on avait qu'on
avait celle - les actions aussi va
apporter son expérience et oui je suis
là pour ça ils sont motivés apparemment
on l'a senti sont bien intégrés il ya eu
peur il ya eu des soucis jusqu'à
maintenant on est contents d'eux sur
cotonou donc pour l'instant tout va bien
donc il va apporter aussi son expérience
de coaching si les bienvenus exact et
ati là bas il a pris en main
avec succès d'ailleurs l'équipe junior
on avait perdu le premier match de
l'équipe des juniors là ils ont joué ce
week-end et ils ont gagné donc coaching
gagnant pour l'instant et justement les
américains ils arrivent à s'acclimater
chaque saison il ya des nouveaux et ce
qu'ils arrivent à s'acclimater à tout
d'abord l'an dernier on avait encore mac
douglas qui était présent depuis
quelques années maintenant après
shenzhen qui s'est très bien intégré à
notre groupe malheureusement il est
parti donc pour relever d'autres
objectifs maintenant les deux américains
qui sont venus on les a bien accueillis
quand ils sont arrivés on a fait des
petites soirées avec eux des petites
fêtes pour les mettre un peu d'ambiance
et non il ya une bonne entente
franchement y'a pas voir il ya aucun
souci ils s'entendent bien avec nous à
l'entraînement c'est une bonne cohésion
d'équipé c'est vraiment pas mal et est
ce que vous sentez que l'équipe est plus
forte que la saison dernière plus fort
que la saison dernière non je pourrais
pas vous assurer je pourrais vraiment
pas le vous rassurer je pense que les
dernières à l'instant t on était plus
fort l'année dernière maintenant on sait
pas ce que ça a donné peut-être qu'au
premier match à rennes surprise on
attend j'attends vraiment le premier
match on attend on va voir ce que ce que
ça va donner mais on n'est sûr de rien
donc l'événement également la nuit
dernière c'était le super bowl donc les
new england patriots ont remporté leur
quatrième sur pas super bowl en
s'imposant 28 à 24 face aux seattle
seahawks donc vous avez regardé match
c'est ça vous étiez tous ensemble si
j'ai bien compris ressemble à la fin du
temps plié on était tous ensemble on a
regardé le match aux dominos pizza et
c'était une grosse ambiance vraiment une
bonne ambiance et justement qu'avez vous
pensé de ce match pas vraiment c'était
un c'était un grand super bowl comparé à
l'année dernière où voilà il ya une
victoire écrasante des 6 octobre 40
points sur les fortunes à lillers c'est
à dire le match est joué jusqu'au
dernier instant jusqu'au dernier instant
on pouvait penser que c'est un blog ses
terres américain voilà vraiment que les
chiots que ça allait prendre parti sur
les patriotes à mach 2 babyloniens comme
on dit chez nous et vous parlez vous
l'avais regardée aussi la première mi
temps durs même un petit peu la première
de la première mi temps
konaté parce que apparemment tout s'est
joué sur la dernière action du match à
20 secondes de la fin ce qu'on voit à
l'écran là
j'ai regretté de s'être couché à 2 watts
bideau fra 88 à coeur et donc il ya un
joueur dont tout le monde parle
aujourd'hui c'est tom brady voilà c'est
un peu une idole pour vous un modèle en
tout cas modèle pour moi pas vraiment
c'est pas vraiment mon pose donc voilà
après c'est un grand joueur qui a acquis
accomplis ce vraiment de grandes choses
et qu'on regarde son parcours comment
ils arrivent en nfl c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment extraordinaire maintenant
moi c'est pas mon exemple personnel mais
c'est un jour incroyable mais c'est un
joueur incroyable ça on peut pas cette
question on peut vraiment pas pas daigné
d'accord et justement tom brady au temps
t il est en cours pourquoi pas bien sûr
ceux prévus avec notre budget on
retiendra bien huit jours à venir oblige
ou non ces voix là même à tom brady à la
retraite depuis disons
merci georges agostino merci de passer
sur ce plateau merci également alexander
zeitung on vous souhaite donc de
réaliser donc vos objectifs cette saison
et tout de suite les résultats du week
end
il y avait du tir à l'arc ce week-end a
trap organisé par la compagnie d'arc de
trappes les championnats départementaux
ont réuni pour cent cinquante personnes
au complexe sportif
youri gagarine on écoute jean yves
florence président du comité à
départemental
tous les championnats départementaux
sont des événements importants celui ci
qui est le championnat salle sa clôture
la saison salle
et après on va passer maintenant saison
extérieure donc là il reste encore le
championnat régional elancourt dans
quinze jours et à guyancourt la semaine
prochaine pour les jeunes et la saison 5
sera terminé
du côté des résultats les
saint-quentinois ont réalisé de belles
performances donc ce week-end chez les
seniors hommes arc classique le
trappistes simon belz a terminé à la
troisième place du classement élan
courtoise mégane minot montel sur la
plus haute marche du podium dans la
catégorie seniors dames les à face qui
termine 3e chez les cadets enfin dans la
catégorie vétérans hommes arc à poulies
ligne montrent un richard goursaud roll
devient champion départemental
en rugby montigny-le-bretonneux n'en
finit pas de gagner les zones de cyril
mûriers enregistre un nouveau une
nouvelle victoire face à provins sur le
score de 22 à 17 un succès sur le fil
qui permet aux inimitiés de monter sur
la plus haute marche du podium de cette
première série toujours en rugby plaisir
se relance dans la course au maintien
les hommes de pierre vidalis ont
remporté une victoire précieuse sur leur
terrain face au 5e tour score final 17 à
11 un exploit qui permet à plaisir de
sortir provisoirement provisoirement de
la zone de relégation
en foot ball trap cale à domicile et
trappistes ont été tenus en échec sur
leur terrain par la parisienne sur le
score de 2 buts partout une mauvaise
opération au classement les ivy noir
restent à la huitième place du
championnat et sont toujours menacés de
relégation
toujours en football mais chez les
filles cette fois l'équipe de
montigny-le-bretonneux s'est lourdement
incliné à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
saint maur le score est sans appel 8 à 4
pour sa mort elle reste donc dernière du
classement avec 8 petits points les îles
montagne vont certainement travaillé la
défense cette semaine à l'entraînement
agenda maintenant
agent dès maintenant
montigny-le-bretonneux va tenter de
poursuivre sa belle série contre
saint-andré à domicile un match qui
s'annonce passionnant
montigny-le-bretonneux et saint-andré se
disputent la première place du
classement si vous voulez assister à la
rencontre et supporter les verts le
match est programmé au stade de roger
couderc à montigny le bretonneux
toujours en rugby mais cette fois ci en
promotion d'honneur saint quentin en
yvelines reçoit ce dimanche à 15 heures
le sixième du classement chalonnais
victoire impérative pour les saint
quentinois qui sont actuellement la
troisième place du championnat
victoire conforterait leur place sur le
podium la rencontre est programmée au
stade de guy-boniface aille en cours
enfin on en a parlé en début d'émission
laisse montigny-le-bretonneux reçoit ce
samedi à 20h30 le mans coleader de
nationale 2 avec le havre lésigny
montagne veulent passer seul en tête
pour cela elles doivent s'imposer face à
leurs adversaires au complexe sportif
pierre de coubertin
c'est la fin de cette fuite sport très
bonne soirée sur tv fil 78